lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
practicar para desarrollar una habilidad
importante observar operaciones
algebraicas y darse cuenta si son
correctas lo que sirve para revisar el
trabajo de otra persona o el trabajo
propio y poder darse cuenta de si uno
hizo las cosas bien o se equivocó y
ubicar en donde se perdió la lógica o
porque no estoy obteniendo la respuesta
que debe obtener vamos a practicar esto
aquí tengo una ecuación 9 que multiplica
a entre paréntesis 2 x más un tercio que
es igual a 39 alguien ya lo desarrolló
ese es el paso 1 paso 2 paso 3 para
llegar a esta solución x igual a 2
lo que quiero que hagan es que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta y vean si esta solución es la
correcta
que cada paso sea lógico y tenga sentido
algebraica mente o ver si hubo algún
error en alguno de estos pasos y de ser
así en cual paso ocurrió el error
resolvamos el problema y veamos si estos
pasos son correctos en el primer paso
llegaron a este 18 por lo que parece que
distribuyeron este 99 por 2 x nos da 18
x y por supuesto también tenemos que
multiplicar 9 por un tercio lo que nos
da nueve tercios o tres enteros esto se
ve bien y por supuesto seguimos teniendo
este 39 aquí a la derecha por lo que el
paso 1 es correcto que hicieron en el
segundo paso de 18 x + 3 pasaron a 18 x
en el lado izquierdo así que debieron de
haber restado 3 en ambos lados de la
ecuación para deshacerse del 3 de la
izquierda así que restamos 3 y tenemos
que hacer lo mismo del lado derecho
aquí también restamos 3 y el resultado
se ve bien 39
36 36 por lo que el paso 2 es correcto
nos queda 18 x igual a 36 y para
despejar x tenemos que dividir ambos
lados
entre 18 lo hacemos así y nos queda x
igual a 36 entre 18 o lo que es lo mismo
x igualados todos estos pasos son
correctos por lo que no tenemos error
alguno aquí incluso pueden sustituir
aquí la equis por el 2 y verán que el
resultado es correcto hagamos otro
ejercicio para ver si podemos
identificar algún error ok
tenemos 8 entre 3 igual a 3 que
multiplica a c + 5 tercios
queremos despejar la pausa del vídeo y
ver si hay algún error en estos pasos o
si no hay error alguna
en el primer paso el lado izquierdo
quedó igual del lado derecho pasamos de
3 x entre paréntesis de más 5 tercios a
13 por lo que vemos que distribuyeron el
33 por 6 13 lo que es correcto ahora
distribuimos 3 con 5 tercios lo que nos
da 5 15 tercios esto de aquí no es
correcto debería ser 5 15 tercios aquí
hay un error en el paso 1
ahora veamos otro ejercicio de práctica
más para ver si podemos encontrar
errores
un cuarto por r 210 inmediatamente de
aquí pasamos a un cuarto de r por lo que
se deshicieron del 2 del lado izquierdo
para hacer esto tenemos que restar 2 en
ambos lados
y nos queda 2 - 2
un cuarto de r por lo que el lado
izquierdo tiene sentido
derecho es diez menos dos nos da ocho y
no 12
aquí hay un error sumaron dos en lugar
de restar dos por lo que ya no se cumple
la igualdad el paso uno tiene error